basta basta parlare di risorse umane
non so se ci avete fatto caso ma ogni
volta che si cerca di descrivere una
persona che lavora in azienda si usano
dei delle parole che hanno a che fare
con la finanza con l'economia con il
marketing risorse talenti quasi come se
già al momento dell'assunzione si
cercasse di vedere qual è il ritorno
dell'investimento di una persona anche
quando si parla di personal branding con
e disciplina piuttosto moderna si
insegna alle persone a promuoversi a
vendersi come se fossero un brand una
marca un prodotto che non è sbagliato
perché in fin dei conti quelle sono un
po le le dinamiche però si si tende a
vedere le persone più come un
investimento che non un vettore di
conoscenza come un vettore di idee di
condivisione di cose interessanti che
poi portano un ritorno dell'investimento
nelle aziende eppure il mondo del lavoro
è profondamente cambiato sono cambiati
gli obiettivi sono cambiati
i modelli è cambiato il modo con cui le
persone accedono anche al posto al posto
di lavoro sono cambiati anche un po i
punti di riferimento quando il mio papà
è diventato dirigente all'inizio degli
anni settanta gli hanno fatto avere una
fiat 128 quando è uscito alla fine del
2000 aveva una lancia k la macchina era
un po lo status symbol di persone che si
differenziavano da tutti gli altri
dipendenti di un'azienda
anche questo è cambiato profondamente
david bevilacqua che è un manager che a
me piace molto è stato vice presidente
di cisco in europa e oggi ha deciso di
fare un vero cambiamento di dedicarsi a
se stesso aperto una sua una sua azienda
racconta sempre come è cambiato il modo
di attrarre le persone nelle aziende e
di come mantenere invece i propri
proprio personale e lo dice sempre che
una volta si attraevano le persone con
la macchina con il posto macchina vicino
al all'entrata con un biglietto da
visita importante oggi ragazzi non
vogliono più un computer un telefonino
hanno il loro anno loro computer hanno
il loro telefonino la macchina
probabilmente non lo usano neanche usano
nuovi sistemi il car sharing e altre
cose hanno bisogno di altro
il mito del posto di lavoro è
profondamente cambiato
ho lavorato a parma per qualche anno una
una zona che è profondamente impattata
dal dall'economia bancarie quando le
mamme accompagnavano i ragazzi a fare
colloqui di lavoro
una delle prime domande era se fosse
disponibile un posto in banca
il mito del posto in banca lo
riconoscerete anche voi non non c'è più
non credo che ci siano tanti ragazzi
oggi che abbiano voglia di entrare in
una banca probabilmente dipende anche da
come le banche si stanno ponendo un po
negli ultimi negli ultimi anni si parla
tantissimo di work life balance questo
equilibrio tra vita professionale e vita
lavorativa se ne parla tanto si
concretizza un po meno probabilmente
anche se nel nostro territorio abbiamo
degli esempi interessanti da barilla
tetrapak e stanno facendo degli
esperimenti da guardare attentamente per
capire per capire come come evolverà
questo mondo del lavoro
tanto di cappello quegli imprenditori
che hanno deciso di mettere una palestra
all'interno della loro azienda
un asilo la lavanderia molto
interessante però è anche vero che se da
noi in italia queste sono un po dei
degli oggetti attendere ancora ci sono
nel nord europa e anche oltreoceano le
aziende che già costruiscono i muri
pensando a questo tipo di benefit ma il
benefit e chi legge un po richard
branson stamattina si si nominava sa che
sta cambiando anche questo e
probabilmente anche da noi vogliamo più
tempo il vero benefit oggi è il tempo
pensate se quella palestra potesse andar
vela cercare a scegliere voi perché c'è
un trainer che mi interesso si fa
un'attività che vi piace magari è vicino
casa
pensate se quell'asilo potete sceglierlo
voi perché c'è un insegnante che vi
interessa perché si fanno delle attività
con i bambini c'è un programma didattico
interessante e magari è vicino casa
potendo andare e tornare senza la
pressione del tempo se le vostre aziende
vi permettessero di usare il tempo come
volete in serenità perché parliamoci
chiaro queste palestre questa e
lavanderia in azienda sono un po gli
escamotage che usano le aziende per
tenerci dentro l'azienda ma non sono
benefici
si chiede più tempo si chiede una
qualità della vita migliore si chiede
più crescita formazione per essere
persone migliori dipendenti migliori si
chiede di essere riconosciuti per quello
che facciamo e dall'altra parte delle
aziende ci chiedono fedeltà senso di
appartenenza vogliono che noi siamo gli
ambasciatori di quei marchi di quei
brand di quelle aziende dove dove stiamo
lavorando si chiedono certo competenze
si chiede passione però come si fa a
chiedere passione le persone non
vogliono più rispondere alle e mail a
mezzanotte quando si è in ferie da capi
che vogliono controllare qualsiasi cosa
vogliono report costanti aggiornati in
tempo reale non vogliono più perdere
tempo e riunioni chilometriche con
quelle cacchio di bottigliette di acqua
minerale dove tutti fanno altre cose
tranne che in ascoltare e seguire la
riunione non vogliono più che qualcuno
si prenda il merito al posto loro
o che rimanere in ufficio solo per far
vedere che si sta lavorando quando
magari abbiamo finito di lavorare 3 ore
fa le persone questo non lo vogliono più
e allora come si fa a fare cambiamento
nelle risorse umane questo questo posto
ancora così atavico così primitivo nel
nei suoi nei suoi processi
quando mi chiedono qual è la
caratteristica che devo avere un manager
per essere veramente un manager che fa
cambiamento io dico sempre deve essere
curioso
la curiosità è la cosa che deve
necessariamente albergare in ognuno di
noi e bisogna fare cambiamento anche nel
modo in cui comunichiamo e non so se ci
avete mai fatto caso ma quando le
aziende si descrivono si descrivono
quasi tutte come leader di mercato se
andate su google ci sono 920 mila
aziende che sono tutte leader di mercato
oppure sono aziende giovani e dinamiche
altre 815mila peccato che anche quelle
aziende che sono veramente leader di
mercato non sono poi così innovative
l'innovazione si dovrebbe fare nelle
scuole ma le scuole non insegnano a
stare in azienda non insegnano a
diventare dei bravi manager
io sono rimasto perplesso quando ho
ascoltato il discorso
dell'amministratore delegato di enel
alla luiss che ha parlato di distruggere
i gangli di potere per fare il
cambiamento che ha parlato di
terrorizzare le persone che non vogliono
cambiare ma il cambiamento non si fa in
contumacia
il cambiamento è un processo lento di
trasformazione è un processo che deve
coinvolgere le persone le deve allineare
le deve far sentire parte di un qualche
cosa
e chiaro che poi dopo 24 ore bisogna
bisogna chiedere scusa per ciò che si è
detto perché non è questo il cambiamento
il cambiamento delle risorse umane deve
avvenire attraverso i piccoli gesti
bisogna iniziare a rispondere ai
candidati che mandano curriculum bisogna
incominciare e oggi abbiamo le
tecnologie per farlo non è che non c'è
bisogno di una persona con una penna che
risponde uno ad uno abbiamo le
tecnologie per farlo ma soprattutto le
aziende e importante che facciano
orientamento alle persone spiegargli
perché non vanno bene per un determinato
ruolo e spiegargli come fare per bisogna
farsi trovare questo signore il
responsabile del personale di air france
che qualche anno fa
l'anno scorso ha licenziato qualche
migliaio di dipendenti attraverso
un'email di sera e chiaro che qualcuno
ha cercato spiegazioni ha provato a
telefonare ha provato a mandare una
risposta almeno questo signore qui non
si è fatto trovare lo hanno trovato loro
giorno dopo
bisogna conoscere i trend i candidati
oggi vanno in altri posti a cercare
lavoro le aziende cercano i loro
candidati in altri posti
bisogna un po provare a innovare anche
questo un bellissimo esempio secondo me
è quello di heineken che
l'anno scorso per cercare uno stagista
ha fatto una sorta di operazione sul web
ovvero ha registrato i tre candidati
finalisti a questa selezione mentre
stavano facendo il colloquio di lavoro e
hanno fatto dei colloqui un po sui
generis ovvero mentre arrivavano in
azienda gli anni che hanno testati
sull'emotività il direttore del
personale li ha accolti ha colto il
primo prendendolo per mano per vedere
che effetto faceva dopodiché ha finto di
svenire durante il colloquio per vedere
se il candidato emotivamente rispondeva
e come in che modo rispondeva ed è stato
molto particolare anche il modo in cui
hanno dato risposta al candidato
vincente durante la finale di coppa dei
campioni
questo candidato era fra le persone che
lavoravano nello stadio e sui cartelloni
sui mega schermi dello stadio apparso il
suo nome la sua faccia e heineken che
gli ha detto guy tu hai conseguito il
posto di lavoro
questa è la faccia che ha fatto quel
ragazzo che stava tenendo il telone ha
continuato a sbatterlo come un pazzo
dalla felicità quest anno ha raddoppiato
hennequin ha creato un portale molto
bello dove puoi mandare il tuo
curriculum ma soprattutto puoi fare un
piccolo test di personalità
sono una decina di domande molto
semplici non è che si richieda
chissà che cosa e ti danno
immediatamente una risposta ti dicono
che persona sei sono sempre risposte
molto positive molto anche divertenti
però servono ad accorciare quella
distanza che c'è fra le aziende e le
persone ti fanno sentire già a casa ti
fanno sentire che in qualche modo si
stanno occupando di te e la fine del
test termina con la presentazione di
alcune delle persone della squadra che
potresti incontrare andando a lavorare
da loro un operazione di brand molto
forte si chiama employer branding c'è
quel modo con cui le aziende invitano le
persone ad andare a lavorare con loro la
parola d'ordine per le aziende e anche
per i candidati dunque differenziarsi
basta con questo curriculum europeo
questo aborto creato dalla pubblica
amministrazione per la pubblica
amministrazione dove ti costringono a
incasellare
dentro a dei box le tue passioni le tue
competenze e i tuoi le tue attitudini
dove vuoi arrivare
basta con i career day questi posti dove
fai delle file chilometriche per trovare
dei ragazzini che ne sanno meno di te
dietro un bancone dove poi si cercano
solo stagisti alla fine bisogna andare a
cercare il lavoro nei posti giusti
e allora bisogna fare un pò
un'operazione non tanto di creatività
come hanno fatto alcune persone questo e
damiano pescara un ragazzo veneto che ha
una grossa passione per i videogame e
l'anno scorso
qualche anno fa per donna ha fatto un
video lo ha mandato alla società che che
lo distribuiva dicendogli non c'è una
traduzione in italiano di questo video e
io so che ci sono tanti ragazzi italiani
che vorrebbero giocarci che sono
appassionati ma non lo capiscono ferma
il video si presenta fa la traduzione di
questo video in diretta dice che lui
potrebbe fare quella cosa e si propone
per farla chiaramente l'esito è stato
straordinario questa ragazza per un
posto di stagista si è fatta fare delle
statuette di lego finte e le ha mandate
i direttori del personale delle aziende
in cui voleva lavorare e di poche
settimane fa
luca sila ha mandato delle scatole di
pasticcini e direttori del personale
delle aziende con cui voleva lavorare
dicendogli insieme ai pasticcini
leggete anche il mio curriculum
è evidente che il lavoro sta girando
tantissimo sul web per cui sul web
bisogna essere preparati bisogna usare
gli strumenti bisogna usare il social
bisogna usare tutto quello che serve per
promuoversi linkedin prima di tutto
sicuramente il posto dove bisogna
presentarsi bene essere convincenti
essere professionali come ha fatto per
esempio luca che nel fare la fotografia
se un po addormentato ne ha approfittato
il suo gatto che è diventato
amministratore delegato di kitekat come
ha fatto alessandro che prima di tutto
ha messo davanti a sé le sue passioni ha
detto prima di tutto i massaggi
thailandesi come ha fatto vincenzo che
ancora deve decidere un po che cosa
vuole fare però intanto è un amante
dello champagne o valeria che lavora in
una società di aeroplani probabilmente
si è fatto la foto durante l'atterraggio
in decompressioni una delle frasi più
brutte che ci perché ci sentiamo dire è
più brutte da ascoltare il dottore in
riunione
scherzi a parte bisogna incominciare a
prepararsi quando si è sicuri di non
avere problemi io incontro decine di
dirigenti tutti i mesi che pensavano che
mai sarebbe successo a loro e invece
hanno perso un posto di lavoro per un
motivo o per un altro persone che non
hanno mai curato un network che non
hanno mai presenziato a qualche evento
interessante che non hanno mai avuto la
necessità e la curiosità di incontrare
persone si sono ritrovate di punto in
bianco senza punti di riferimenti senza
posti dove portare i loro curriculum
senza una rete di relazione efficace e
questo chiaramente ha giocato tantissimo
a loro sfavore bisogna incominciare ad
ascoltare le persone bisogna
incominciare a dare credito alle persone
ad avere cura delle persone e per questo
che io penso che bisogna smettere di
parlare di risorse umane cambiare i
paradigmi e incominciare a chiamarle
umane risorse grazie